I think I need to lose a little weight.
President Trump just announced tariffs on fifty billion dollars of Chinese goods,
and half the planet seems to be screaming about a trade war. Neither the administration nor its critics are right
nor its critics are right because the tariffs will actually have little impact. The administration is
right that China coerces US companies
into transferring technology, and steals
other intellectual property outright.
They're also right that the WTO has
failed to prevent this and US action is
overdue. But the 25 percent tariff on 50
billion dollars will only cut imports
from China by about $20 billion. Imports
from China rose twice that much in 2017.
We won't even notice these tariffs. For
that reason, China doesn't have much
reason to act on its own to retaliate.
They will certainly threaten to do so, in
part to scare other countries from
copying the US. But they need trade with
the US more than the US needs trade with
China. So it's in China's interest for
this dispute to stay limited. Right now,
this is a tempest in a teapot, but
eventually people are going to notice
that very little has actually changed,
and that "eventually" may coincide with
the start of the 2020 presidential
election campaign. We're not done with this yet.
What do you think about taking a
tougher stand on China? Let us know in
your comments. Also, let us know what
other topics you'd like our scholars to
cover in 60 seconds, and be sure to like
and subscribe for more research and
videos from AEI.